Die Rasenfunk-Schlusskonferenz. Alles zum letzten Bundesligaspieltag.
Das ist doch schön, dass ich mit meiner Jingle-Auswahl, mit der Intro-Auswahl den lieben Frank gleich zum Lachen gebracht hab. Ich hab einen Klassiker der Rasenfunk-Geschichte rausgeholt, Wolf Fuss, der uns nicht kennt. Hallo Frank, schön, dass du hier bist.
Man weiß es nicht.
Man weiß es nicht. Also ich hatte Kontakt mit ihm, vielleicht aber nicht den allererfreulichsten, deswegen lassen wir das an dieser Stelle aus, die Geschichte. Du erinnerst dich ja wahrscheinlich.
Lass uns auch an dieser Stelle über erfreulichere Dinge sprechen.
Genau, genau. Du bist hier. Warum bist du denn hier, Frank? Das ist ja, Moment mal, da ist das überhaupt erlaubt?
Ja, ehrlicherweise weiß ich mir auch nicht, ob wir das Ganze noch nicht im Rasenfunk Royale erzählen. Ja, ergibt ihr aufsehen.
Aber macht ja nix. Ist ja gar nicht so schlimm, weil wir hören ja jetzt vielleicht noch einige, die es damals nicht gehört haben. Also ihr könnt euch sicher sein, wir schauen da jetzt noch mal genauer hin. Und uns liegt natürlich auch viel daran, dass wir euch da keinen Quatsch erzählen und dass die Produkte tatsächlich fair produziert sind. Und da gucken wir so gut hin, so gut es uns möglich ist. Und sind da auch zufrieden. Weil die Frage von Alex war ja, wie zufrieden wir aktuell mit unserem Partner sind. Und da sind wir tatsächlich sehr zufrieden.
Exakt. Und keine Zweifel haben wir. Und wenn alle Zweifel ausgeräumt werden, dann hat man auch ein Gefühl der Sicherheit zurückerlangt.
Genau. Dann machen wir mal weiter mit dem lieben Zaunpfahl. Ein Stammgast im Forum. Der Rasenfunk ist ja, sagt er, soweit ich das mitbekommen habe, schon bei einigen Fußballspielen offiziell akkreditiert auf der Pressetribüne gewesen. Dazu zwei Fragen. Erstens, was ist eigentlich der Vorteil, wenn man Journalist selbst beim Spiel anwesend ist? Max nimmt ja extra die An- und Abreise in Kauf, wobei Zeit am Wochenende vermutlich eher eine stark begrenzende Ressource ist. Daher nehme ich an, dass das Stadionerlebnis einen Vorteil gegenüber dem Scouting-Feed hat.
Ja, also, Scouting-Feed habe ich ja gar nicht. Den gibt es ja nur beim Samstagabend-Topspiel. Ansonsten habe ich keinen Zugriff auf den Scouting-Feed, sondern nur auf die normalen Fernsehbilder, die ihr auch seht. Und das ist dann auch schon der Vorteil. Fußball ist immer besser zu analysieren, wenn man im Stadion ist, weil man da eben immer die 22-Kamera hat. Also alle 22 Feldspieler sofort auf einen Blick sieht und eben auch Dinge aufnehmen kann, die von den Kameras nicht eingefangen werden. Das ist der eine große Vorteil, wenn man im Stadion ist. Der zweite große Vorteil ist, man hat die Möglichkeit, in der Mixed Zone mit Spielern zu sprechen und man kann den Trainern Fragen stellen. Und da habe ich sehr große Lust drauf, weil ich ja auch immer Fragen habe nach Spielen. Das sind die beiden großen Vorteile, weshalb es sich für mich lohnt, in Stadien zu gehen und die auch dann Mehrwert bieten, auch für die Analyse im Rasenfunk. Und den großen Nachteil hat Soundfarm schon völlig richtig erkannt, wie auch nicht anders zu erwarten von einem Stammhörer. Der Zeitaufwand ist der Grund, warum ich das nicht an jedem Wochenende mache, sondern sehr, sehr ausgewählt bisher. Denn eben in der Zeit, in der ich zu einem Stadion fahre, von einem Stadion wegfahre, in der Mixed Sound warte, auf die Pressekonferenz warte, kann ich mindestens zwei weitere Spiele gucken. Plus ich sehe ja dann diesmal nur ein Spiel, habe nicht auf einem zweiten Bildschirm noch eins mitlaufen. Das heißt, in der Regel verliere ich drei Spiele, die ich dann wann anders gucken muss. Das schränkt mich halt sehr dabei ein, wann ich mal im Stadion sein kann. Also eben als Beispiel, wenn der FC Bayern, also München liegt natürlich nahe, weil ich eben in München wohne, München und Augsburg wären so die Möglichkeiten, als erstes Mal irgendwo ins Stadion zu gehen. Wenn die am Samstag oder am Sonntag spielen, ist es so gut wie ausgeschlossen. Ich war einmal beim Samstagabend Spiel zwischen Bayern und Gladbach. Und das habe ich bitter bereut, weil ich erst sehr spät wieder zu Hause war und dann noch anfangen musste, die ganzen anderen Samstagsspiele nachzugucken. Ich konnte irgendwie noch die erste Halbzeit von den 1530-Spielen sehen, aber sonst nichts. Und bei Freitagabendspielen, da ginge es mal. Aber ansonsten, der Zeitverlust ist tatsächlich da. Und deswegen passiert das nur auch so sporadisch.
Dann schließt er noch an und wir wissen, wie so eine Pressetribüne eigentlich aussieht.
Das ist unterschiedlich. Also auf jeden Fall Stuhltisch, Internet und Strom ist inzwischen eigentlich bei allen mit dabei. Und dann hast du in manchen Bundesliga-Standorten hast du Bildschirme, auf denen dann auch das Signal des übertragenen Senders durchläuft. Das hat insofern den Vorteil, dass man da einen zeitlichen Versatz von so ungefähr zwei Sekunden drin hat. Das ist sehr günstig, weil man hat quasi die strittige Szene gesehen und kann sie dann gleich bewerten und hat noch mal die Nahaufnahme, die einem ja sonst im Stadion fehlt. Es gibt aber auch Stadien, da gibt es nur einige wenige Monitore. Ein paar brauchen die natürlich, also die Kommentatorinnen und Kommentatoren, die haben immer noch mal Monitore, die müssen ja auch sehen, was der Zuschauer und die Zuschauerin sehen kann. Und dann ist es sehr unterschiedlich. Also beim FC Bayern zum Beispiel, da habe ich dann keinen Monitor.
Jetzt haben wir ganz viel Diskussion im Forum. Ich hoffe, ich übersehe nichts, aber der nächste, der mir mit einer Frage direkt aufkommt, ist der Arribo. Grüße an dieser Stelle. Auch ein langjähriger Stammhörer und Stamm-User im Forum. Wie stark will er wissen, war die Entscheidung zur GmbH von den häufiger zitierten Problemen mit dem Finanzamt getrieben? Kann man eigentlich sagen, gar nicht, oder?
Naja, ein bisschen schon, ehrlich gesagt. Also mir ist das schon alles hart auf den Sack gegangen, um das jetzt mal so zu sagen. Und ich bin auch mit dem Ergebnis der Prüfung nicht zufrieden. Nein, ja, ich hoffe dann doch. Weil irgendwie hab ich das Gefühl, dass ein Teil dieses ganzen Heckmarks mit dem Finanzamt auch damit zu tun hatte, dass ich vor dem Finanzamt halt quasi einfach ein Dude bin, der von ganz vielen Dudes und Dudettes da draußen Geld überwiesen bekommt. Und ich hoffe, dass es ein bisschen besser wird, wenn das jetzt eine GmbH ist, den Geld überwiesen bekommt. Kann doch sein, dass ich da sehr blauäugig bin. Vielleicht glaube ich da zu sehr an das Kompetente im Finanzbeamten. Es tut mir leid, ich muss es einfach so sagen. Diese ganze Steuerprüfungsnummer und so weiter war einfach... Ich bin nach wie vor nicht happy damit. Ich kann ja nichts dafür, dass wir so ein tolles Finanzierungsmodell haben, was einfach auf Nettigkeit basiert.
Ja, es ist tatsächlich wahrscheinlich wirklich das Ungewöhnliche daran, wie wir das ja vorhin schon erwähnt haben, dass dieses Thema der freiwilligen, gegenleistungsfreien Spenden, die für das Finanzamt im Unternehmenskontext eher ungewöhnlich sind.
Erst dachten sie Geldwäsche, dann dachten sie, wir bescheißen sie. Und dann haben sie ganz, ganz ausführlich in unsere Bücher reingeguckt, die natürlich völlig sauber waren. Warum sollten wir da irgendwas irgendwie faken wollen? Wir wollen ja alles richtig machen und haben dann festgestellt, ach so, dann bist du kein Unternehmer. Du hast ja gar keine Gewinnerzielungsabsicht, weil du machst ja die Sendung trotzdem. Und naja. Und das, denke ich, wird jetzt mit der GmbH schon ein bisschen schwieriger, uns jetzt zu sagen, dass wir keine Unternehmer sind. Bin ich mal gespannt.
Außerdem will er noch die Merchfrage von Alex ergänzen um die Frage, wann der Rasenfunkturs endlich kommt.
Ja, Frank.
So, jetzt muss ich gucken, wo wir noch mal weiter. Zaunpfahl hat noch mal angehängt. Habt ihr Erwartungen bzw. Erfahrungen von anderen Podcastern, wie viele Daueraufträge nicht umziehen? Methodisch inkorrekt hat er ja auch schon mehrere, Fragezeichenkontowechsel hattet ihr mit denen Kontakt. Also wir haben grundsätzlich mit den Jungs von Methodisch inkorrekt immer mal Kontakt. Ich hatte da schon mehrfach Kontakt. Aber wir haben jetzt nicht explizit deswegen nachgefragt, oder Max?
Ich hab auch nicht nachgefragt. Also ganz liebe Grüße an die beiden. Aber da gab es eher andere Themen zuletzt, die auch wichtiger waren.
Wir haben keine konkreten Erwartungen. Wir befürchten leider, wie schon erwähnt, dass uns da ein gewisser Prozentsatz abhanden kommen wird. Wie viel ist es, können wir jetzt noch nicht sagen. Aber tatsächlich hängt das auch sehr stark von der Hörerschaft ab. Da sind jetzt Erfahrungen wahrscheinlich gar nicht so sehr hilfreich. Wir tun jetzt einfach, was wir können, indem wir euch aktiv und hoffentlich nicht zu aggressiv an mehreren Stellen informieren und darauf hinweisen. Max wird das sicherlich auch in den kommenden Sendungen tun. Die Geschichte mit den Einsend-Überweisungen hat Max ja vorhin auch schon erwähnt. Das ist eben auch so ein Weg, um diejenigen zu erwischen, von denen wir sonst keine Kontaktdaten haben. Jetzt hoffen wir einfach mal drauf. Ich glaube, dass wir da im ersten Vierteljahr 2023 sehen werden, wie sich das entwickelt. Es wird auch mit Sicherheit ein paar Monate dauern. Und leider, wie auch schon erwähnt, sind dann die Spenden, die Anfang des Jahres noch auf dem alten Konto landen für uns. Zwar trotzdem schön, aber erst mal ein bisschen problematisch, weil wir die nicht so einfach in die GmbH kriegen und auch nicht mehr so einfach für Gästehonorare verwenden können. Genau. Also insofern, wir wissen es nicht genau, wir sind besorgt. Aber gute Dinge, dass wir das hinbekommen.
Genau, wir freuen uns immer schon wahnsinnig über jede Überweisung, die aufs neue Konto reinkommt. Also ich denke, dir geht es genauso. Ich habe meine Push-Notifications noch an, weil ich das eben sehen will, wie viel kommt auf das neue Konto schon an.
An der Stelle ist der Thread dann etwas eskaliert. Alex hat noch den Max und Frank Wackelkopf als Merchartikel gefordert und die Belle wollte einen Baby-on-Board-Autosticker mit deinem Kopf drauf. Auf einem Babykörper. Ich will das gar nicht weiter kommentieren. Ich habe dann an der Stelle zwischendrin zur Ordnung gerufen im Thread. Und dann ging es noch ein bisschen weiter. Hammes Millner, der hat natürlich noch gefehlt als regelmäßiger Fragesteller in diesen Q&As. Er fragt allerdings nach den Auswirkungen des WM-Boykots, die wir schon besprochen haben an dieser Stelle. Er will aber auch noch wissen, was die Pläne für den Rasenfunk 2023 sind.
Glaub ich. Also jetzt erstmal das bestehende Programm soll weitergehen. Es wird dann eine Frauen-WM-Berichterstattung geben, wie die aussieht. Da bin ich aber in meinem Kopf schon am Planen, aber noch nicht. Meine Hände sind noch nicht am Planen. Ich hab noch keine Mails und so weiter verschickt. Und alles weitere muss man sehen. Aber ich denke, ihr könnt davon ausgehen, dass das, was ihr jetzt im letzten Halbjahr erlebt habt, das soll eigentlich der Rasenfunk 2023 sein. Das heißt, viele Kurzpässe, viele Schlusskonferenzen und immer mal wieder Tribünengespräche. So wie es in einer perfekten Rasenfunkwelt auch sein sollte.
Er will außerdem noch wissen, ob du schon etwas zu den Vorverkäufen beim Ulli-Buch sagen kannst oder darfst. Wie es da läuft, er drückt die Daumen für einen Platz in den Top 20. Die Chancen dafür sind in der ersten Woche immer besonders hoch, da dort dann auch alle Vorbestellungen mitgezählt werden. Er nennt das dann Buchbranchen-Hack.
Korrekt, das ist absolut korrekt. Ich habe keinerlei Überblick.
Ich kann sprechen, was dazu sagen.
Ich habe keine Vorverkaufszahlen, denn auch der Verlag hat keine Vorverkaufszahlen. Das hat mich ehrlicherweise selber etwas überrascht. Es ist so, dass der Verlag sieht, wie viele Exemplare wurden von den Buchhändlerinnen und Buchhändlern vorbestellt, aber das sind ja noch nicht verkaufte Exemplare. Und die Zahl ist halt wunderbar hoch. Aber das heißt halt leider gar nichts. Ich weiß deswegen nichts, bin selbst ganz überrascht. Ich hoffe auch sehr, dass man in, also die relevanteste Bestsellerliste ist ja die Spiegelbestsellerliste. Wenn man da draufkommt, dann hat man die Chance, dass dann ein Buch quasi so ein Selbstläufer wird. Also das Ziel des Buches wäre es, quasi auszubrechen aus unserer Blase und eben auch Leute zu erreichen, die weder den Rasenfunk kennen noch Elfleben kennen, die einfach nur wegen der Sache sich für das Buch interessieren. Und dafür müsste man aber so ein bisschen Durchhaltevermögen haben. Also in der ersten Woche reinkommen in die Bestsellerliste und dann aber hoffentlich auch drinbleiben, denn dann liegt man in den Buchhandlungen eben anders präsentiert. Dann hat man auch mal Laufkundschaft und dann müssen wir den Leuten ja noch genügend Zeit geben, dass sie diese 400 Seiten lesen und dann noch jemandem anderen empfehlen. Also deswegen, das sind sehr viele Dans und sehr viele eher konditionale als temporäre Dans. Also es ist nicht zu erwarten, dass das Uli-Buch irgendwie zum Bestseller wird und bleibt vor allem. Ich habe im Sportradio 360 darüber gesprochen, dass Caro Simon mir sofort das Du angeboten hat und dass das ein sehr, sehr schönes Interview war. Aber ich mir im Nachhinein gefragt hab, ob ich vielleicht zu wenig Journalist war in dem Moment. Weil ich eigentlich eben Leute, also ich sieht sie immer, alle Gäste im Rasenfunk. Außer eben es wird explizit irgendwie vorher von ihnen angesprochen, dass sie duzen wollen, weil ich eben dieses Angeduze nicht mag. Ich kenne ja die Leute nicht. Und ich will denen ja respektvoll begegnen und vielleicht auch kritisieren. Und das habe ich da angesprochen. Und deswegen hat er gesagt, ab jetzt siehst du mich nur noch.
Okay, gut, dann schreibt er, wenn ich das neulich bei Sporträder 360 richtig verstanden habe, dann wird sich Max Jakob aus der Zukunft alle Spiele eines Spieltags der ersten Fußballbundesliga der Männer und Frauen in Deutschland ansehen, um anschließend zwei separate Schlusskonferenzen bzw. eine Schlusskonferenz und einen Kurzpass dazu machen zu können. Nun meine Frage, was bedeutet das für Formate wie den Kurzpass oder das Tribünengespräch, aber auch Sondersendungen wie den Royal oder anders formuliert? Gab es die Überlegung, dass nicht auch eine andere Person als Max Jakob Ost die erste Fußballbundesliga der Männer oder der Frauen in Deutschland für den Rasenfunk machen könnte? Ich befürchte nämlich, dass aufgrund der Doppelbelastung des Max Jakob Ost die kleineren Formate wie auch eventuelle Sonderfolgen, ähnlich wie damals als 11 Leben priorisiert wurde, etwas zu kurz geraten könnten, was mich persönlich sehr dauerte, da mir die genannten Formate sehr viel Freude beim Hören bereiten und sie zudem anders als die meisten Schlusskonferenzen recht gut altern, wie ich finde. Deshalb, weshalb ich immer wieder einmal zum Beispiel in den alten Royal hineinhöre.
Ja, also das Gute ist, wir haben ja quasi schon eine Fallzahlgröße, nämlich die letzten Monate war das ja schon so, dass ich 15 Spiele pro Wochenende gesehen habe und dann diese Sendung gemacht habe. Und da würde ich sagen, hat kein Format in irgendeiner Weise gelitten. Es gab weiter Ligatouren, es gab weiter Sendungen zur zweiten Männerbundesliga und es gab auch Tribünengespräche. Und eins davon ist ja schon aufgenommen, aber noch nicht veröffentlicht aus verschiedenen Gründen. Also ich habe ja sogar noch eins mehr gemacht, als die Hörerinnen und Hörer bisher hören könnten. Also bisher hat das wunderbar geklappt und war eben nicht so wie bei LF Leben, wo eben manche Dinge zum Stillstand gekommen sind. Ganz im Gegenteil eigentlich finde ich. Also gerade bei der Legatur haben wir jetzt noch eine bessere Regelmäßigkeit reinbekommen. Und dennoch hat er aber total recht, dass es eigentlich zu viel ist. Es ist eigentlich auch nicht gut, 15 Spiele innerhalb von, naja es ist nicht immer am Wochenende, am Montag gucke ich meistens auch noch mal zwei Frauenspiele oder ein Frauenspiel. Aber das ist zu viel, das weiß ich auch. Das soll auch nicht für immer so sein. Und in meinem Kopf habe ich da schon ganz viele in denen gehabt, wer mal so moderieren könnte, neben mir, dass ich das nicht immer an einem Wochenende alles machen muss. Aber da hängen ja noch ganz viele andere Sachen dran. Geld unter anderem, also das haben wir ja vorhin schon angesprochen, da müsste sich noch ein bisschen was tun. Aber ich würde jetzt schon mal davon ausgehen, gewöhnt euch an den Gedanken, dass nicht immer der Max der Moderator ist. Weil so wie es aktuell ist, wie der Rasenfunk ist und wie wir wollen, dass er ist, geht es irgendwann nicht mehr, weil es einfach zu viele Sendungen sind und zu viel. Und dann leidet vielleicht auch irgendwann die Qualität. Also das ist ja jetzt auch gar nicht irgendwie nur aus Sicht von uns gedacht, sondern auch aus eurer Sicht gedacht. Also gewöhnt euch mal an den Gedanken, es wird bestimmt auch in 2023 wieder andere Moderatorinnen und Moderatoren im Rasenfunk geben.
Und das Ziel, das haben wir ja im Kontext der GmbH schon erwähnt, ist tatsächlich auch, das zu verstärken und da eventuell jetzt auch mehr Möglichkeiten zu haben, uns da Hilfe zu holen. Tasty Marshmallow, Marshmallow hat im Grunde das Ähnliche gefragt, darum überspringe ich den ersten Absatz mal. Dann kommt aber noch das zweite Frage, würde mich einfach interessieren, ob ihr in der Finanzierung eher eine ideale oder eine reale Lösung verfolgt. Allein die Umstellung auf die GmbH hat natürlich ein wenig mehr Interpretationsraum ermöglicht, aber mich würde mal abseits davon interessieren, habt ihr einen Großspender, der euch in ihren Gegenleistungen, einfach Geld freigibt? Es sind häufig die Bedingungen an Werbung geknüpft, was ihr ja nicht wollt. Ich kann mir einfach vorstellen, dass ein bestimmter Organisatierer euch Geld zur Verfügung stellt ohne Gegenleistung. Habt ihr so etwas oder baut die freiwillige Spende tatsächlich nur auf einzelnen Beiträgen auf? Gerade in Bezug auf die Honorare finde ich das interessant. Kann ich mal direkt beantworten? Hätten wir auch gerne mehr.
Großspender?
Großspender, die uns ohne Gegenleistung einfach Geld frei geben.
Also wenn es ohne Gegenleistung wäre, dann könnte ich mich auch damit anfreunden. Ansonsten finde ich ehrlich gesagt eigentlich die Kleinspender geil.
Nein, es ist ja wunderbar. Wir wollen das ja natürlich so. Und insofern, um die Frage zu beantworten, verfolgen wir weiter die ideale Lösung, glaube ich, wenn ich das so richtig interpretiere. Und die ist aber für uns ganz real, nämlich seit 2016 mittlerweile. Und da gibt es keinen Großspender. Oder gibt es einen Max, von dem ich nichts weiß?
Du wärst ja der Erste, der davon erfahren würde. Nein, es gibt keinen Großspender. Und das soll ja auch genauso sein. Und das ist ja auch der große Vorteil. Denn wenn der Großspender dann aufhörte zu spenden, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, dann würde uns da ein großer Teil unserer Einnahmen fehlen. Und das soll eben nicht passieren. Deswegen ist auch die stabilere Variante. Wir haben natürlich eine große Variante in den Beträgen, die wir überwiesen bekommen haben. Also in meinem Kopf habe ich schon ein paar Großspenderinnen und Großspender. Die möchte ich ganz herzlich grüßen an dieser Stelle. Die nehme ich monatlich einfach sehr, sehr viel Geld überweisen. Aber das ist jetzt, glaube ich, nicht das, was er meint. Das sind nicht die Beträge, auf die er da angespielt hat, glaube ich. Es liegt immer noch unter einem Gästehonorat. Das könnte doch die neue Kategorie sein. Willst du Großspenderin werden, dann musst du mindestens einen Gästehonorat überweisen pro Monat.
Nee, also die Frage können wir klar verneinen. Das sieht beim Rasenfunk intern tatsächlich auch so aus, wie es nach außen aussieht. Wir bekommen ausschließlich die Hörerspenden. Und das sind ganz viele Einzelspenden. Und da sind wir auch sehr glücklich drüber. Der Punkt ist ja auch so ein psychologischer. Weil wir dadurch auch einfach immer das Gefühl haben, direkt von unseren Hörern bezahlt zu werden. Und nicht von einem Gönner, der dann, wenn es auch vielleicht vermeintlich ohne Gegenleistung ist, aber wo dann intern trotzdem immer ein gewisser Druck entsteht, wenn da mal ein Kommentar kommt oder so, das dann demjenigen recht zu machen. Also könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass das ein Problem ist. Wir waren nie in der Situation, Gott sei Dank. Und insofern gebe ich Max auch recht. Es ist auch tatsächlich die angenehmere Variante, das so zu haben, wie es jetzt ist.
Und halt viel stabiler. Wir haben jetzt die Ungewissheit des Kontowechsels, die ist da. Und so eine kleine Ungewissheit, was macht die Rezession, die kommen wird? Aber im Großen und Ganzen habt ihr uns wieder und wieder bewiesen, dass ihr uns nicht fallen lasst. Und zwar nicht einer lässt uns nicht fallen, sondern ein paar Hundert lassen uns nicht fallen. Weil es bisher immer so war, dass auch nur eine Andeutung im Rasenfunk gereicht hat, dass sich an den Spenden etwas bewegt hat. Deswegen wollen wir das auch nicht überstrapazieren, weil wir wollen das nicht ausnutzen in irgendeiner Art und Weise. Aber deswegen mache ich mir auch tatsächlich für 2023 jetzt überhaupt gar keine Sorgen mehr. Vor ein paar Monaten war das noch ein bisschen anders. Als es so leicht nach unten ging, hatte ich ein bisschen Sorgen. Weil ich wusste, was ich gerne alles machen würde und wie viele Gäste ich gerne einladen würde. Aber jetzt mache ich mir gar keine Sorgen mehr. Weil ich weiß, zur Not sind das in drei Sendungen aufeinander mal eine Erwähnung und eine Bitte. Und dann werden genügend von euch quasi da sein, um es aufzufangen. Und das ist wirklich wie ein warmer Mantel. Und ich möchte noch mal ganz herzlich die Finanzbeamtin grüßen an dieser Stelle, die die Steuerprüfung durchgeführt hat. So ist es halt im Rasenfunk. Ich kann doch auch nichts dafür.
Doch, ziemlich viel kannst du dafür. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Jetzt will Alex nochmal ganz ernsthaft von mir wissen. Er schreibt, es gibt ja genug Leute, die Max kennen und ihm auch ab und an persönlich sagen, dass er sich mal etwas rausnehmen soll, wenn es zu viel wird. Sein Eindruck ist aber, die sind ja alle erfolglos damit. Daher die ganz ernste Frage an mich, gibt es rein theoretisch, ihr seid ja dann GmbH und auch formal gleichberechtigt, die Chance, dass du irgendwann mal sagst, stopp Max, das wird jetzt zu viel, du brauchst eine Pause und wir ersetzen dich jetzt in dieser Woche durch Eva Lothar, Mark oder wie noch immer. Nein, Alex, ich bin aufgrund der Gleichberechtigung leider nur gleichberechtigt und nicht mehr berechtigt und auch nicht weisungsbefugt. Insofern, mehr als ihm gut zureden kann ich dann im Zweifelsfall auch nicht.
Aber das tust du ja oft genug, Frank. Und komm, ein bisschen verfängt es doch auch. Ich habe einen Urlaub gemacht während der Zeit, das war doch wirklich toll.
Er klagt ja, ich nicht. Noch nicht. Genau, das war es dann eigentlich auch schon. Wir haben dann ein paar Kommentare, die jetzt aber glaube ich an der Stelle nicht sein müssen. Und ansonsten haben wir alle Fragen, soweit ich das sehe, beantwortet. Und sind durch.
Da ist das verrückt.
Für dieses Jahr.
Frank, ist das vielleicht das erste Mal, dass wir innerhalb der Zeit geblieben sind, die wir uns vorher vorgenommen haben?
Ja, wir haben anderthalb Stunden gesagt, wir sind jetzt bei 1.25. Das ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Gibt es noch was, was du den Hörern und Hörern sagen willst zum Jahresausklang?
Na ja, natürlich will ich mich bedanken. Also vor allem erstmal bei allen Hörern und Hörerinnen definitiv fürs Zuhören und fürs Mitdiskutieren im Forum, auf Social Media, überall. Und natürlich im Speziellen bei den Supporterinnen für die tolle Unterstützung. Ehrlich gesagt hätte ich persönlich auch mit mehr Rückgang gerechnet dieses Jahr. Freut mich sehr. Ich glaube eben auch durch die von dir schon erwähnte breite Masse, durch die vielen, dass das alles jetzt so gut verlaufen ist bis hierhin. Wir werden, wie du schon gerade erwähnt hast, wahrscheinlich in eine Rezession laufen. Und da muss man erstmal noch sehen, wie das läuft. Man muss jetzt sehen, wie es mit der Kontoumstellung läuft. Aber ich glaube, wir haben jetzt keinen Grund, übermäßig besorgt in die Zukunft zu gehen. Wir haben ein paar tolle Ideen für das nächste Jahr, worüber wir sicherlich in den kommenden Wochen und Monaten noch sprechen werden. Und ich glaube, der Rasenfunk wird ein noch spannenderes Projekt in Zukunft. Und da freuen wir uns sehr drauf, oder ich mich persönlich auch sehr drauf, das mit euch als Hörer und natürlich mit Max. Alles zu machen und zu gestalten.
Absolut, ich auch. Und dann möchte ich mich anschließen. Also ich glaube, gerade der letzte Punkt, den du gesagt hast, der ist nochmal ganz wichtig. In der Rückschau wird es glaube ich so sein, dass man mal auf die Geschichte des Rasenfunks blickt und sagt, naja, 2014 damals gegründet, 2016 damals das Support-Modell eingeführt. 2019 war dann das erste Jahr, in dem ich den Rasenfunk hauptberuflich gemacht habe, alle meine anderen Dinge zurückgefahren habe. Da hat sich dann eben auch, also all das, worüber wir jetzt sprechen, Kurzpässe und so weiter, das ist ja alles dann auch erst so wirklich gekommen, weil es dann erstmal auch ging. Und ich glaube tatsächlich, das nächste Ding wird sein in der Rückschau, dass wir dann sagen, und dann 2022 bzw. 2023, da kam die GmbH und dann ging es nochmal weiter. Und ich glaube, so wird man das alles sehen und ich finde das total toll, dass wir das machen, auch wenn es anstrengend ist und wir da immer die Dinge zedenken und so weiter und man eben so viel Ungewissheit hat. Aber Frank, solange wir die Sache zu zweit machen, weiß ich, wir kriegen das immer hin. Weil wir uns sehr gut ausgleichen, glaube ich, weil wir uns aufeinander verlassen können. Das ist schon echt sehr cool, dass es diesen Podcast schon so lange gibt und dass wir den so lange gemeinsam machen. Und ich sag mal so, mit dir würde ich zu jedem Notar laufen, um irgendwelche GmbHs zu begriffen, weil es immer Spaß gemacht hat.
Und wer jetzt genau zugehört hat, der weiß auch, 2025 wird der ganz große nächste Wurf kommen. Nach 16, 19, 22, kann es nur 2025 werden, wenn wir dann, keine Ahnung, unseren IPO feiern und an die Börse gehen. Keine Ahnung.
Jeden Maastrathaus getauft und richtet das ganze Ding zu Grunde innerhalb von drei Tagen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das dauert dann keine drei Jahre, sondern eher drei Tage, ja.
Ja, wer weiß, vielleicht war ich... Mein Ziel muss natürlich sein, dass ich 2024 dann bei der Zeremonie der Europameisterschaft, der Männer-Europameisterschaft in Deutschland, dass ich da auf dem Feld bin, wie ein anderer, viel zu bekannter Koch es jetzt beim WM-Finale war. Auch das habe ich mitbekommen, ohne jemals danach gefragt zu haben. Das ist mein Ziel. Und dann geht es 2025 natürlich richtig ab. Ich schicke dir danach einen Link, wenn du willst. Danke, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für ein fantastisches Rasenfunk-Jahr. Wir können auch deshalb so transparent sein, weil es uns immer gedankt wird von euch mit eben inhaltlich wertvollem Feedback darauf. Wir sind sehr stolz darauf, dass man so gut mit euch reden kann, dass auch immer noch das Forum so ein wunderschöner Ort in diesem Internet ist. Und das auch bei YouTube, das möchte ich jetzt mal ausdrücklich sagen, weil ich habe manchmal über YouTube geschimpft, ich finde auch bei YouTube gab es ganz fantastische Diskussionen in diesem Jahr und ich persönlich spüre da schon, dass sich da etwas gedreht hat, in der Art und Weise wieder kommentiert hat. Vielleicht ist es eine Folge dessen, dass ich manchmal ein bisschen draufgehauen habe an dieser Stelle. Vielleicht aber hat sich es auch einfach so entwickelt in jedem Fall. Ihr seid definitiv auch gemeint, liebe YouTube-Kommentatorinnen und Kommentatoren, vor allem Kommentatoren, seien wir ehrlich. Aber ja, das ist einfach schön, dass wir diesen schönen Ort haben. Vielen Dank euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Dann machen wir jetzt Schluss, Frank. Dann wünschen wir euch, wenn ihr das noch vor den Weihnachtstagen hört, wunderbare Feiertage. Wenn ihr andere Feiertage feiert, dann wünschen wir euch da einfach jetzt viel Erholung. Bleibt vor allem gesund, bleibt dem Rasenfunk treu. Und danke, dass ihr mit dabei wart. Frank, jetzt hast du noch die Möglichkeit.
Vielen, vielen Dank. Auch dir, Max. Schöne Feiertage euch allen. Und einen guten Rutsch ins neue Jahr.
Einen guten Rutsch. Macht's gut, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer.
Das war die Rasenfunk Schlusskonferenz.